the Joe Rogan experience so now that you
know Kido what are you doing with your
diet try to be healthy no not really no
no but it definitely has made me
understand sugar more smoking cigarettes
uh I'm vaping a lot more but yeah how
much cigarettes do you smoke a day half
pack still yeah but I don't smoke in my
car so I my cigarette has gone down like
because of that because of that like 70%
that's good yeah what would you think if
we decided to do that as a project
higher you a trainer and how are you -
nutritionist would you be down with that
sure like film it as a project yeah what
would you like what do you weigh now
would you you don't have to tell
everybody but would you like to get down
to but see that's the problem with night
when when I got down whatever like 15
years they are 13 year ago whenever when
I whatever I think it was like 65 pounds
or something and I I just thought I'd
look like I had had AIDS or something we
just used to yourself looking big yeah
but I think some people like they have a
body shape or look that looks way but
way better with a little shove on them
than they do if they look I don't know I
feel like you know what Joey Diaz said
when he lost a lot of weight when he
lost a lot away my [ __ ] head look too
big yeah exactly but you know what that
is it's like you got to build up your
body cuz something happens to people
when they gain weight your head gets
bigger it's like when people get really
heavy their head gets bigger and I don't
know if like a biologist can back us up
on this some sort of science but it
seems like really overweight people
their head gets really big - like it
grows with them which kind of makes
sense because there's like your bones
definitely get bigger and thicker when
you lift a lot of weights right now when
you're 450 pounds you're carrying weight
everywhere you go so everything's got to
be thick like I always said if Ralphie
may wound up losing all that way he'd be
able to kick a hole through a [ __ ]
wall cuz that guy's carrying around 500
pounds everywhere he goes his leg
muscles had to be gigantic like
underneath all that his legs must have
been [ __ ] huge so if you could just
put some muscle on while you're losing
the fat see that's the difference like
when you were on that look at you look
great then dude look at you sexy [ __ ]
now look at what you think you look bad
no okay that's an okay man I was
thinking more why did you look Jamie how
great you look you look [ __ ] great
there I was think more of that time when
the photo of me and you with that weed
guy that died at the 4/20 Awards where I
just look like an eight that's when I
was I at my lowest week the one who has
although of can't think of his name
he has weed named after him he's very
famous oh yeah yeah stroke yeah we were
hanging out there me and you and I just
that's when I was at my skinniest I
think I was like 160 155 or something
like that
I remember but that I just look like ass
it feels so light though you move around
get places quicker lighter definitely
have more energy that's better
dude you can do this what would you
think about doing this as a project like
we'll announce it on the podcast we'll
start it off would you be into doing
something like that yeah I mean
eventually not like not like this month
cuz I have to go to Australia how this
started now Australia you know when are
you going back what you do until Tony
out there yeah doing kill Tony and then
uh yeah so this month is all I'm on the
road okay
[Applause]